I'm not jealous of many actors in this
business but among those I am in the
arse there's Jason Robards he's married
to a lovely lady with soma he's in
pictures so mine he came here from the
Broadway stage so did I but he can go
back here is mr. Jason Robards
thank you Bob but I assure you you
couldn't go back any time undecided
which I like it here when writers
finished writing actors stop acting and
directors complete directing the film
they have exposed goes into the hands of
the men and women who in the final
analysis make it a moving picture our
editors for the best achievement and
film editing this year the nominees are
Charles Nelson for Cat Ballou Norman
Savage for dr. Zhivago michael luciano
for the flight of the Phoenix Ralphy
winters for the great race and William
Reynolds for the sound of music thank
you
and the winner is William Reynolds for
the sound of music
there's a secret to winning an Oscar for
film editing and that is when in doubt
cut to Julie Andrews you can't lose